she stashed her kid in the trunk because
she thought she'd get the coven funk
it's a reprieve in one mom's fight for
treating her son like samsonite yeah
here's an update on some crap we told
you about on monday this houston mom and
teacher aren't they all
was accused of putting her covet
positive kid in the truck so she
wouldn't get exposed to the virus but a
judge said there's no probable cause to
charge her and that's texas where
everyone gets the electric chair even
those arrested for stealing electric
chairs
but her case could still go before a
grand jury
meanwhile supreme court justice neil
gorsuch drew the ire of the new york
times the rag shaming him for not
wearing a mask during oral arguments my
favorite kind
about biden's vax mandates quote gorsuch
had to know that his masklessness
could make other justices uncomfortable
gorsuch's lack of a mask inside the
courtroom seemed needlessly risky and
disdainful of his colleagues
but how more comfortable do these
justices need to be they're already
wearing robes
and not much else what i heard is true
but perhaps gorsuch doesn't wear a mask
to keep all the ladies at bay right
because as it turns out masks make you
hotter and not just in terms of lip
sweat a humongous british study
of 43 people
found that women were more attracted to
pictures of masked men than those who
were maskless they must go for the
looters
one researcher thinks it's because
people focus more on the eyes
but we know that's bs
it's really all about hiding what the
brits are known for
yeah
those gnarly teeth
usa usa
i don't even think they watch this show
over there so what do they know but we
wanted to put this theory to the test
here in the states
yeah mom the doctor said the rash on my
back isn't contagious so that's good oh
i gotta go my blind date's here all
right bye-bye
hi you must be chris
yeah um
i don't think this is gonna work what
why is just the vibes all wrong and
you're not wearing a mask oh oh i'm
sorry i have one right here
i got my mask right here
[Music]
hello gorgeous
what are you doing later and then every
day after that
[Music]
i don't know what
what is gene trying to tell me
and why don't i not like it
[Laughter]
cat who's behind this mask study let's
be honest huh come on who's behind it
i don't know
i don't know but it's not i think only
big mask cat yeah
no i think i believe in big mask yes i
know i do because i now without makeup
i'm probably more attractive with the
mask because of the rosacea that i've
developed because of the mask so i've
actually gotten less attractive and now
i need the mask when i didn't need it
before i was i was uh perfect uh and now
i'm
and now i'm not i'm sick of it and you
know i noticed like all the tv that we
watch there's not they're not all
wearing masks which makes sense because
the actors need to be able to convey the
emotions of the characters so that makes
sense what does it make sense is why is
that not something considered important
for the rest of us in real life that's
true that's true by the way rosacea
sounds better than it is it's yeah it's
not it's a beautiful name rosaceae
yeah it's like it's like a
type of wine i'll take the rosacea but
it's not it's actually not it's no fun
chadwick and i can't believe you're
making light of it like this you know if
you were i'm not laughing at my skin
condition how dare you humiliate my
co-host
why don't you know
covering half your face makes you more
attractive
it's just government propaganda if you
ask me yeah that's true though if you
put on a match you get them covered i
can't just grow a beard over my rosacea
give yourself a few years cat you know
uh but
you know uh
what was i gonna ask you
what are the upsides of wearing a mask
though and i know cat understands this
you can hide things in your mouth
like hide things in your mouth
if you need to go get you know you need
to pop something in your mouth before
you get on a plane or go into a concert
you don't want a tab of acid anything
you put you put whatever you need inside
a little bag you put in your cheek and
you put your mask up no one's figured
this out except me
well that's i hadn't thought of this
either
use it exploit you're single-handedly
going to make tsa more of an aid in the
asteroid you need to open your mouth
you can't stop there
i don't know where i am because you know
what
i don't need to talk to you anymore you
make me sick to my stomach
all right dagon uh you got the masking
study you got gorsuch you got the lady
with the trunk
which one do you want to a tack i will
well the kid in the car was 13 in the
trunk and that's a hell of a lot more
cool riding in the trunk than riding in
the car with your mom wow that's so true
but
i will see cats rosacea and raise her
chronic styes and blepharitis oh
blepharitis
but that's in your eyes
but how do you get the mask up to your
eyes you weirdos
disgusting breath um yes i am here to
bring you
news yes that the the instances of eye
infections styes and blepharitis like
eye problems have gone through the roof
like 50 increased double since covet
because of the mass it causes excess oil
production in your eye glands oh my
goodness so again i have a mask on oh
don't just ignore this giant sky oh my
or this goiter on my neck that's the
size of like kermit the frog
this is all i have fairly decent teeth
this is all i've got going for me don't
look at my crow's feet i need an
opposite of a mask
i need like
dark sunglasses dear penthouse forum
i was recently on the gutfeld show
you know uh
that could explain what happened to
pelosi's eyebrows right if it if it all
kind of moves upward because their
eyebrows have you seen them lately yeah
she owes money to mcdonald's for those
that was like boom those were the arches
she was selling cheeseburgers after
that's true um what do you
of these three stories which one it's
all so sad yeah they're like oh masks
make you hot no they don't no no they
don't and you know what else makes you
hot tequila booze
am i right over there drunky
oh my god yes i'm a crippling alcoholic
you know it's true but it's also the
people are lying because they're kind of
adult they have to virtue signal right
they're being told you know the common
assumption is that if you don't wear a
mask there's something wrong with you
yeah so they're doing this study and
it's like they go oh they they actually
know what the study is just by looking
at it when they oh if they see the
picture with the mask they go oh i get
it i'm supposed to pick that right it's
and it's like somebody doing a study
trial like we're going to make mass cool
and television yes or there's someone at
the cdc with a serious mask fetish yes
whose time is common he just doesn't
want to let
can you imagine if you have a mask
fetish this is the golden age
oh it's true it's true it's like when
you when you have a foot fetish and they
have commerce foot locker commercials
right
the real mass fetish though is like you
can barely breathe out of it and it's
got a zipper yes um
people who are those are good times dear
penalties
all right
enough of this crap up next would you
name your kid clayton payton or satan